what we're going to do in this video is
start talking about forces that exist
between even neutral atoms or neutral
molecules and the first of these
intermolecular forces we will talk about
are London dispersion forces so it
sounds very fancy but it's actually a
pretty interesting and almost intuitive
phenomena so we are used to thinking
about atoms and let's say say we have a
neutral atom so it has the same number
of protons and electrons and so that's
all those are all the protons and the
and the neutrons in the nucleus and then
it'll have a cloud of electrons so I'm
just imagining all these electrons kind
of jumping around that's how I'm going
to represent it and let's imagine and
this is definitely not drawn to scale
the nucleus would actually be much
smaller if it was but let's say that
there is an adjacent atom right over
here and it's also neutral maybe it's
the same type of atom it could be
different but we're going to say it's
neutral and it also has an electron Crow
cloud and so if these are both neutral
in charge how would they be attracted to
each other and that's what London
dispersion forces actually to explain
because we have observed that even
neutral atoms and neutral molecules can
get attracted to each other and the way
to think about it is electrons are
constantly jumping around
probabilistically they're in this
probability density Cloud where electron
could be anywhere at any given moment
but they're not always going to be
evenly distributed you can imagine that
there is a moment where that left atom
might look like this just for a moment
where most of or maybe slightly more of
the electrons are spending time on the
left side of the atom then on the right
side so maybe it looks something like
that and so for that brief moment you
have a partial negative charge this is
the Greek letter Delta lowercase Delta
which is used to denote partial charge
and on this side you might have a
partial positive charge because remember
when it was evenly distributed the
negative charge was offset by the
positive charge of the nucleus but here
on the right side because there's fewer
electrons here maybe you have a partial
positive on the left side you have where
most of the electrons are in that moment
partial negative now what might this
induce in the neighboring atom think
about that pause the video think about
what might happen in the neighboring
atom
then well we know that like charges
repel each other and opposite charges
attract each other so if we have a
partial positive charge out here on the
right side of this left atom well then
the negative electrons might be
attracted to it in this right atom so
these electrons here might actually be
pulled a little bit to the left so they
might be pulled a little bit to the left
and so that will induce what is called a
dipole so now you'll have a partial
negative charge on the left side of this
atom and then a partial positive charge
on the right side of it and we already
had an a a randomly occurring dipole on
the left hand side but then that would
have induced a dipole on the right hand
side a dipole is just when you have the
separation of charge where you have your
positive and negative charges at two
different parts of a molecule or an atom
or or really anything but in this world
then all of a sudden these two
characters are going to be attracted to
each other or the atoms are going to be
attracted to each other and this
attraction that happens due to induced
dipoles that is exactly what London
dispersion forces is all about you can
actually call London dispersion forces
as induced dipole induced dipole forces
they are they become attracted to each
other because of what could start out as
a temporary imbalance of electrons but
then it induces a dipole in the other
atom or the other molecule and then they
get attracted so the next question you
might ask is how strong can these forces
get and that's all about a notion of
polarizability how easy is it to
polarize an atom or molecule and
generally speaking the more electrons
you have so the larger the electron
cloud larger electron cloud electron
cloud which is usually associated with
molar mass so usually molar
mass then the higher polarizability
you're going to have because you're just
going to have more electrons to play
around with if this was a helium atom
which has a relatively small electron
cloud you couldn't have a significant
imbalance at most you might have two
electrons on one side which would cause
some imbalance but on the other hand
imagine a much larger atom or a much
larger molecule you could have much more
significant imbalances three four five
50 electrons and that would create a
stronger temporary dipole which would
then induce a stronger dipole in the
neighbors that could Domino through the
entire sample of that molecule so for
example if you were to compare some
noble gases to each other and so we can
look at the noble gases here on the
right hand side if you were to compare
the London dispersion forces between say
helium and argon which one would you
think would have higher London
dispersion forces a bunch of helium
atoms next to each other or a bunch of
argon atoms next to each other well the
Argon atoms have a larger electron Cloud
so they have higher
polarizability and so you're going to
have higher London dispersion forces and
you can actually see that in their
boiling points for example the boiling
point of helium is quite low it is -
268.7 de C while the boiling point of
argon it's still at a low temperature by
our standards but it's a a much higher
higher temperature than the boiling
point for helium it's at
85.8 De C so one way to think about this
if you were at
say
270° C you would find a sample of helium
in a liquid state but as you warm things
up as you get Beyond -
268.7 de C you're going to see that
those London dispersion forces that are
keeping those helium atoms together
sliding past each other in a liquid
state they're going to be overcome by
the energy due to the temperature and so
they're going to be able to break free
of each other and essentially the helium
is going to boil and you're going to
enter into a gaseous State the state
that most of us are used to seeing
helium in but that doesn't happen for
Argon until a good bit warmer still cold
by our standards and that's because it
takes more energ energy to overcome the
London dispersion forces of argon
because the Argon atoms have larger
electron
clouds so generally speaking the larger
the molecule because it has a larger
electron cloud it'll have higher
polarizability and higher London
dispersion forces